are you doing today sir good minutes oh
I'm doing excellent I get to talk to you
about the unbreakable sequel which is
[ __ ] crazy okay
Knight tells you you're gonna be making
this movie how much is he telling you
way back when about the whole arc of
this movie and how much is he saying I'm
gonna give you the script and I want you
to read it nothing we started
unbreakable he said okay this is the
first movie of the trilogy and it knows
the last we heard of it and then you
know movies out I guess people for some
reason they didn't think it was
successful I guess because it didn't
make as much money as I see dead people
or whatever and it was all a sudden was
like okay well I don't know if I'm gonna
do it yet but I'm gonna do it that I
don't know when I'm gonna do it so from
that point on it's like every time I saw
was like are we ever gonna make this
movie and I didn't hear anything and
hear anything he really didn't have an
answer and then one day he called says I
just made this movie called split I want
you to watch I was like why he's like
just watch it and we'll talk so he set
up a screening for me I watched it I see
the tag I don't know
so what's that mean he said well this
means that this movie makes money then
we'll make you know what I'll call the
third part of the trilogy we'll use this
as two and that'll be done a third part
so you then he tells you you're gonna
make glass heat Elton and how much is he
telling you then about how because the
third I can't talk spoilers but there's
a lot going on in the third act mm-hmm
and how much did you know about that was
he telling you that like or was he be
anyone telling us anything he was just
saying you know that this movie is going
to be you know the third part of the
unbreakable trilogy and I mean I'm
locked up in this place and David Dunn's
out and this is two weeks after her
split ends basically so Eliza's in there
but Elijah being Elijah is very aware of
what's going on in the outside world
unbeknownst to all those other people
around them that's not a spoiler of any
sort so when you get those two people
together in the same place he's in it's
almost like he planned it
you know so he gets to put his master
plan in motion the you know proved that
there are people like this in the world
there is a great scene when it's all of
you guys in the hospital and this is in
the trailer it's it's a great room yes
in the pinker and bubblegum room Oh what
is it what was it like filming that
scene because it's it's just so cool to
see the four of you acting together in
that dynamic of everyone having a part
to play well for me you know it's like
sitting there watching I think that was
the first time I got to see Sara in
action and interacting with all three of
us in an interesting sort of way because
you know my job is to sit there and just
be be Elijah on whatever it is they've
given them but trying to figure out an
active way to be passive sure in that
situation you know that lesson they give
you and or tell you about in acting
school acting skills oh listen react you
know so my basic job was to sit there
and listen you know and not really react
because you don't want people to think
he's that cogent right now
you